hey amy can we have a second no i'm kind
of in the middle of something you
oh yeah well
[Laughter]
yourself all right all right traffic is
shut down civilians are being funneled
into checkpoints good i just wish my
guys over here could be a little more
efficient
yeah i'm looking at you detective fuzzy
paws this is amy hates dogs amy or amy
extra stressed amy it's both amy's i'm
under a lot of pressure and also that
dog is a piece of trash
okay amy someone lost your pen girl
gina you better be joking that pen is my
best friend and i will straighten
captain holt oh that's fine it's just a
pen
it's just a pen you bumbling son of a
[ __ ]
you just ruined my life i hope you get
hit by a truck and a dog takes a dump on
your face
nothing to see here just a little
hypoglycemic rage move along
i'm so sorry hitchcock that's not me i'm
never like that
that's okay it's my fault i shouldn't
bump your cashew
cashew it was an almond you idiot i hope
you drown in a tub
i hope you have annual semester aneurysm
after aneurysm
oh guys captain rosa
oh please hear me from land oh
no no no no no no no no oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh welcome to the
phone shut your gun
mouth i'm so sorry no i'm not we have a
crisis we have to go let's go
cold cold cold gold
you did it how'd it go well
the first ten minutes were really
terrible the diaper did not fit
it was for a baby but then i relaxed
and i found my inner strength i think
the lesson here is that as women
we no no you close that truck again i
will kill you you hear me i will kill
you
the only way we're gonna win us if we
team up good point i guess my response
is
rotten hell crap-face also i love you
and i treasure you
and you bore me gosh you're being so
mean
do it more i hope you die we're almost
to the hospital are you there yet what
room are you in
the break room what why there isn't
enough time i have to have the baby here
but me and my crazy crew make it to the
hospital
that's our birth story oh screw your
bird story just get here
so yeah it's a little tough right now
but i think the worst is behind us
why are you taking so long to cook my
freaking oatmeal
she'll be okay okay
i think i got it i just have to tighten
this here
and here we go please work
come on come on
wow [ __ ] really do be crazy can you
distract her i got this
hey me they come out with any new
binders recently i don't want to talk
about binders rosa all right that was my
big gun she's just gonna feel this
sir you're right i failed you santiago
i want my officers to respect the chain
of command but i never want anyone to be
so terrified of me that they repress
basic emotions i'm a terrible captain
stop that
you are not a terrible captain santiago
face facts i'm garbage
no this is about me and my issues with
authority you've been great
wrong i've been a disaster i can't
believe you would blame yourself for
this how
stupid are you so stupid i'm such a
stupid head the fact that you think this
has
anything to do with you is insane do you
even oh my god i'm yelling at you yes
you are you're in the zone keep going
oh okay i can't believe you lost my pen
that was careless
and rude and and it was a real jerk move
santiago
you did it and i am so sick of you
playing your damn classical music in
your office all day
it's too loud we can all hear it okay
well this is
you shut your mouth when i'm talking to
you santiago right too far i'm sorry
this is all very new for me okay well i
don't want to get mad right now cause i
know amy's worried about you
ah no screw that noise how dare you call
jake selfish
he just wasted his entire honeymoon
trying to take care of you while you
wallowed in your
misery like a little baby that seems a
little harsh who does it
i don't give a hoot oh damn for the last
five years all i've done is give a hoot
about you
and what you think gave a hoot about you
as a boss gave a hoot about you as a
mentor i gave a hoot about you as a
friend
she gave so many hoots not anymore after
the way you've acted and what you just
said to jake
i don't give a who what you think and i
really don't give a hoot if you decide
to quit the nypd so
do it i'm all out of hoots i'm hopeless
now what i want to say is jake coming
holly gennaro
what the hell do you think you're doing
huh showing my unborn baby how an ass
gets kicked
all right cortez time for your checkup
no thank you i feel fine
no you don't it's your uterus it's gonna
explode
come with me stand back everyone you're
all in the splash zone
oh this ute's gonna boot here we go
what the hell we agreed you weren't
gonna do that you disobeyed a direct
order from your handler yeah
i did because that order was crap the
next 14 hours are going to be hell
but in the end you will have the
satisfaction of knowing that you've
finally done something worthwhile with
your lives
i kind of think the police work i don't
have time to stroke your damn ego
sergeant
let's make a wedding hey fuzzy paws i'm
paying you to work not lick your
butthole truth is every time i look at
it i want to die
and take you with me i hope your dog
helps with neck pain she's help with
anything
i made it up ah i knew it amy listen to
me very carefully
if you and jake are thinking of trying
you are ovulating like crazy right now
you take that helmet off before i knock
it off what your basal temperature is
off the charts
this is a good thing we have 14 minutes
to find a hacker you're not gonna get
back in time but everybody else is there
right i mean it seems weird to have this
big thing happen without me we talked
about this amy you have an unhealthy
fear of missing out on work you have
foam out this isn't foam out it's not
like i'm freaking out or anything
out of my way you won't [ __ ] as time is
mine
i'll be there in 10 minutes i love you
don't solve it without me the doctor
said that it could take a while
i know it's just we're doing everything
right and it's still not working what
kind of perfect person do you have to be
to get pregnant
we're having a baby oh
what in hell i finally got all the
lambda news back into holding
lambda news it doesn't matter i'll read
your notes later i didn't take any notes
what the hell
jake do you even love me says the woman
who never once sent me flowers
never mind i've been your co for four
years by now you should be able to stand
up for yourself
even if that means telling me off you're
right just say the word and i will tell
you off
okay tell me off about losing your pen
oh
right now okay well makes me feel
pretty annoyed good go on it grates my
cheese i mean
it just really grates my cheese
grrr oh santiago you're faking
faking what did you hear that
gur just admitted okay fine i was faking
the whole time
but i only did it because i wanted you
to enjoy it that ruins it
it's supposed to be good for both of us
it was good just because i didn't get
angry doesn't mean i didn't get anything
out of it
but the whole point is for you to get
angry
did you even get close uh what about
your last ceo
could he make you angry well you know
what i don't want to know
don't tell me i don't want to know
you